we have a voicemail number that number
is
219 to david p i have something special
for you today
my live stream viewers may already be
familiar with this we have a number of
regular callers to the show many of whom
have been calling in for a long time
you've got troy york
you've got the san antonio troll you've
got the kansas troll who hasn't called
in for a while
we have our friend the eggman he's a
friendly regular caller
there's all these regular callers we
have a new caller
who we are calling re peter like peter
the name peter
re-hyphen peter because he will just
call
and call and call repeating the exact
same things over and over again i
introduced him to the audience two weeks
ago on a live stream where he called me
six times in a row with the same message
last week he called me 15 times in a row
with the same message
i don't want to deprive the tv and
podcast audience
from this so i've received 10 more
voicemails
just take a listen to this okay i'm just
going to give you a sampling each
voicemail is two to three minutes long
we'll just listen to a few seconds
here's the first one
david the gossip show i'm calling about
you're talking about this virus listen
to me very carefully
you're not going to understand this
because you don't you're just not that
smart
99 of the people who get the virus
survive the virus you only have a
only one percent out of the people that
get the virus
pass from it okay so that's voicemail
number one then number two
david the gossip show listen to me very
carefully this is about the kobe 99
of the people who get it survive it that
means you only have one percent
of people that get it that don't survive
it
99 99
so that goes on for two minutes then
another voicemail coming in
oh sorry here we go i'm gonna repeat
myself again
david the gossip cell and like i said
david you act like a little girl you you
belong in a dress
and then with some lipstick on it high
heels
the corona virus okay it's actually from
china it's actually the china virus
that's worked because that's where it
came from
anyways 99 of the people who get the
corona virus
so that went on for three minutes which
is the maximum that our system allows
call number four this is for david the
gossip show
about the coronavirus 99
of the people who get the virus survives
the virus
that was two more minutes here's
voicemail number five
i'll say it one more time david about
the coronavirus
99 of the people who get the coronavirus
they survive the coronavirus that means
just a little over one percent of the
people who get it
don't survive the virus voicemail number
six
david the gossip show this is real
simple
we have forensic proof that these
dominion machines
oh boy do uh certain things to flip
votes so now he switches to dominion
voicemail number seven
these dominion machines we have forensic
evidence evidence numbers which don't
lie and then voicemail number eight
it's real simple these dominion machines
are designed for fraud okay and then so
there's five
more um can isn't it insane that this is
like my part of my job
um i don't know what to tell you my
friends
i don't know what to tell you but the
the world is in rough shape
i think that any anything more specific
as a commentary about this
would really not do it justice the world
is in rough shape we've got a great
bonus show for you we will talk about
the new uk strain of the coronavirus and
its implications
we will talk about uh a lot of other
things make sure you are a member and
you will get instant access to the bonus
show
sign up at joinpakman.com coupon code
always available
fresh start to save a bundle
off of the membership of your choice